a network state is a highly aligned
online community with a capacity for
Collective action that crowdfunds
territory around the world and
eventually gains diplomatic recognition
from pre-existing States so we talked
about was the alignment of online
communities and the capacity for
Collective action yep well one
Collective action it could be a thousand
people liking a tweet right if you can
get a thousand of a thousand people
doing it but a much higher level much
higher bar is a thousand people
crowdfunding territory and actually
living together just like people current
physical space in physical space and not
all in one place that's critical just
like Bitcoin is a decentralized currency
the network saves a recipe for a
decentralized state-like entity okay
where it starts with
um you know for example two people just
get you know they become roommates they
meet in this community they become
roommates okay they get their place
together or 10 people get a group house
or eventually 100 people just buy a
small apartment building together and
guess what they start getting Equity not
just paying rent okay these are all
people who share their values and now
they can crowdfund territory together
now of course they don't just jump
straight from a thousand people liking
something to a thousand people
crowdfunding something what I described
in the middle is you do a lot of meetups
you get to know these other people
before you decide to live you know
collectively with them once you live
with them you start to get a network
effect for example if those 100 people
want to learn Spanish or Turkish or
Vietnamese they could all have a
building where they're doing Vietnamese
immersion right and that's something
which they get a benefit from being
physically around the other people that
the pure digital wouldn't give them to
quite the same extent right
um and so crowdfund territory around the
world crucially not just one place
they're all connected by the internet
just like Hawaii's two thousand miles
away from the Continental us but both
sides think of them as American but the
people on Hawaiian people in the
continent yes what's the role of having
to have territory if most of the
exchange so presumably as technology
gets better and better the communication
the intimacy The Exchange of ideas all
happens in the digital world what's the
importance of being able to crowd fund
territory well because we're still
physical creatures you you can't
reproduce yet digitally right there's
still lots of things it's all about sex
well that's got to be part of it you're
going to want to re you know reproduce
are we talking about a cult well
it's not a call you know why can't you
just like take a trip why is it not a
cult it's not called because a cult is
very internally focused and it's it's it
tries to close its members off from the
outside world this is much more how
America itself is populated where there
were lots of towns like Penn is named
after William Penn or the founder of
Texas like Sam Houston right lots of
towns like the Oneida commune in in you
know Northern New York they've recruited
and they became a town and they became
actually the Oneida
um glassware company kind of you know
makes makes glassware out of there all
of these communities are opt-in
voluntary communities we're not simply
like Cults that were closed off from the
world they were meant to set an example
to the world of what virtuous living
look like and they were trying to
recruit from the rest world they're
exporting Goods to the rest of the world
right so it is
um it's yes reproduction it's you know
marriage and kids and so on but it's
also just hanging out and it is just the
physical world is very high bandwidth
there's lots of stuff you know it's fun
to just go and have a dinner in person
just to hang out to build things
moreover there's also lots of innovation
that can only take place in the physical
world
um you know look I'm you know one of my
sayings in the book is cloud first land
last but not land never
okay in many ways what one of the
problems the book solves is Teal's
problem of you know we have innovation
in bits but not atoms right we can build
a billion dollar Company online but we
need a billion permits to build a shed
in San Francisco right how do you
reconcile that well
what is stopping the innovation in atoms
it is a Thicket of regulations what are
those regulations ultimately a social
construction if you lean into the you
know whole deconstructionist you know
School of thinking you can deconstruct
and then reconstruct the state itself
given sufficient social consensus online
okay if the population Nevada had 100
consensus you could just dissolve every
law in Nevada in theory and then build
new ones okay so the online consensus of
getting people to agree on something is
Upstream of what happens offline
so once you have consensus in bits the
human consensus also you know
cryptographic consensus cryptocurrency
consensus
then you can resiate the world of atoms
the reason we can't reshape the world of
atoms right now is because you don't
have that consensus of Minds okay for
example in SF anything you do there's
going to be 50 of people who are against
you like so you that's just a recipe for
gridlock whereas if you have a bare
piece of land that everybody agrees on
you can get you know 70 000 units get
set up in burning man in just a few days
okay that's the power of what when you
actually have human consensus and one
way I talk about this also in the book a
little bit and this isn't going to go
much more into detail into V2 I think
that this says 100 democracy as opposed
to 51 democracy 51 democracy which is
the current form of government is 49
dictatorship because the entire premise
of democracy is about the consent of the
government right that's actual
legitimating underpinning principle and
uh in so far as 49 did not consent to
the current you know president or prime
minister or whatever
um let's say presidential system first
pass the post okay
um insofar as 49 did not consent or in a
in a prime minister system it could be
like 60 or more didn't consent to the
current leader those folks are having
something imposed on them that they did
literally did not vote for moreover
campaign promises are non-binding so
whatever they voted for they can
effectively be defrauded you know the
actual voter fraud is when a politician
promises X but does not do it it's as if
you bought a can of orange juice and it
actually drinking its milk or it's
nothing right so all of that is
routinized all of that is accepted we
have this thing which is just the
minimum possible amount of democracy of
51 okay and what happens is then that 50
tries to Ram something down the 49
throat and then the next election it's
now 51.49 the other way and then they
Ram it back and that's how you get the
Seesaw that is just splitting countries
apart right the alternative to that is
you build a consensus online you go and
get some God forsaken patch of territory
actually the worst the territory the
better why because it's like burning man
nobody cares right the nicer the piece
of land the more the people are going to
argue about it but starlink has repriced
the world basically all kinds of pieces
of territory that were previously you
know they're far away from natural ports
they're far away from natural resources
all kinds of pieces of territory around
the world now have satellite internet
and so what you can do is again the map
is being reopened right we were talking
about earlier the map is being reopened
you can gather your community online
they're now capable of collective action
you can point here this place has great
Starling coverage you go there like the
Verizon guy you know can you hear me now
good right you see that the coverage is
good there you drive out there you test
it out maybe you do it with mobile homes
first right this by the way is its own
thing
there's DMB and there's there's nimbi
and there's EMB but I actually also like
himbi okay
what are those so NIMBY is not in my
backyard don't build in cities yimby is
let's build high density buildings
really tall buildings and so on cities
there's a third version which uh is
Hindi uh it's my little coinage which is
horizontal sprawl is good why horizontal
small because to build a skyscraper to
build a tall building in a city you have
this enormous permitting process all of
this stuff which has to get done it's
expensive it's time consuming the way
that cities were built if you go back to
the V1 what does the startup City look
like it looks like something like
burning man it looks like the cities of
the Wild West they were not multi-story
buildings right they were basically
things that were just like one story and
someone could have it there in the dust
and then you build roads and stuff
between them they can move them around
it was a much more Dynamic geography and
so when you have that as a vision of
what a startup City looks like right now
you've got something there's there's a
company I found it called kift which is
like van life there's a lot of stuff in
construction that that makes us feasible
the so-called man camps uh for for
fracking um where people can just do
like like companies like a Greco their
power uh you can bring water all the
stuff on site so it's easy to actually
snap this stuff to grid relatively
speaking if you've got horizontal space
you pick the space you crowd from the
territory now you've got a city okay and
the last bit is uh eventually again's
diplomatic recognition from pre-existing
States and this is the part that people
you know different people will be with
me up to this point and then they'll say
okay that's the part I disagree with or
how are you going to ever do that right
they'll say yeah you can build an online
community I believe you can get them to
do Collective action and of course
people have crowdfunded land and moved
in together doing it a larger scale all
that I believe how are you possibly ever
going to gain diplomatic recognition
from pre-existing States you dumb
delusional Tech bro right that's a
common thing okay that's about the tone
of it as well right and so first I would
say uh sovereigns are already out for
business they're inking deals okay uh
Nevada aimed to deal with Tesla to build
the geiger Factory El Salvador has
Bitcoin as its National currency Wyoming
has done the Dow law where ethereum is
now recognized where you can have
on-chain incorporations that are
recognized by Wyoming law
um Virginia and New York negotiate with
Amazon for hq2 tuvalu signed a deal with
GoDaddy for the dot TV domain Columbia
signed a deal for the dot Co domain and
on and on on sovereigns are open for
business sovereigns are doing deals with
companies and and with currencies
sovereigns at the level of cities like
Miami or New York where the Mayors are
accepting their their salary in Bitcoin
um States like you know Wyoming or
Nevada has its new private cities
legislation or entire countries like El
Salvador So when you say Sovereign by
the way you mean the old school physical
nation states governments Fiat States
Fiat States okay but but the Fiat isn't
the thing that makes a state well maybe
no it's a state's geographical location
it is is something where uh they're both
right so basically it's a play on word
so just like Fiat currencies
cryptocurrency we will have Fiat oh
country and crypto country right and in
fact you can think of the Fiat and
crypto version of almost anything one
thing I'll come to later is a big thing
the big thing I think comes after
digital currency is digital passports
okay so and that's a big part of this
this whole networks I think we shouldn't
come back to but
so that last bit the reason I just
mentioned all those deals between
sovereigns whether at the city
U.S state or U.N listed country level
okay and on the other hand so that's on
one side of the market and the other
side are the
um companies and the currencies why
could we not have online communities
right so let me uh making those CLS so
uh diplomatic recognition
but are aren't you still
attached to the responsibilities uh that
come from being a member of a sovereign
old-school nation-state so can you
possibly Escape that so yes and let me
give you a concrete example Israel okay
why
um you know people talk about you know a
lot of people are like oh abology just
he took this from snow crash or some
sci-fi book they'll reference remember
actually if uh there's many different
references of the book this is not the
only reference but a very important
reference that I think is much more
important to me than snow crash which is
which is good a good book whatever but
it's fictional is George by Theater
herzl which translates as the Jewish
State and that led to the foundation of
Israel and that's very real it's worth
reading because it's amazing theater
herzl was like a tech founder okay in
the book he was writing about the death
of distance in 1897 why because
steamships could take you across you
know countries okay and he like it's
just you know amazingly smart and
practical guy we just handled all these
various objections and he said look
you know the Jewish people you know our
choices are either a assimilate and get
up the culture or B some people are
thinking communism is a good idea I
disagree with that we should do c build
our own country right and that was
considered totally crazy what we did was
he a wrote a book b started to fund C
organized a semi-annual conference the
you know World Zionist Congress and the
fund and the Congress are still going
today crucially there were a bunch of
intermediate stages between the book and
the idea and then the actual state of
Israel in 1947 for example
um that you know the folks who were
committed zionists got together and
started crowdfunding territory in what
is now Palestine and in fact though
Palestine was only one choice in the
book they also had Argentina as a choice
this is my concept Cloud first land last
and lands a parameter you can choose
right other places that were considered
at various points like Madagascar
birobitzen and the former Soviet Union
right so the land was a parameter
Palestine went out because of its you
know historical religious importance now
by the way one thing I'm sure are some
like some fraction of yours will be like
oh my God like all the bad stuff to have
I'm obviously not denying that there's
enormous amounts of controversy and so
on that attends Israel I consider myself
generally produce really I'd also
consider myself Pro Palestinian I fund
lots of Palestinians and so forth so
I've I'm leaving that part out that huge
conflict or you know for for now okay
and you might say that's airbrushing it
I don't mean it to do that I'm saying
here is the positive things they did can
we take the positive and not have the
negative and I'll come back to how we we
might swap those parts out but let me
just talk about this a little bit more
so one of the things that happened was
committed zionists went in crowdfunded
territory in what is now Israel and they
knit it together right why because when
you're physically present on territory
yes in theory like the the British
Empire wasn't controlled Over The
Sovereign okay in practice who were the
boots on the ground the facts on the
ground right there's the people who are
actually tilling the land and building
the buildings and so and so forth it
like who had the claim there is like the
people who are present okay now
um this this territory this network of
territories eventually
um became the basis for or part of the
basis for what became Israel now
I'm fully aware that the exact
configuration of what territory belongs
to Israel what territory belongs
Palestinians this is an enormous topic
of dispute okay but I just point this
out to say the process going from book
to crowdfunding territory to a sovereign
state where people were now citizens of
Israel as opposed to the British Empire
is not some fictional thing but did
happen and within the lifetimes of some
of the older you know they're in their
80s now but in the lifetimes of some
older people okay so so it's not
impossible in fact it has happened right
okay but for that step then perhaps
hopefully is a better example because in
this particular like you said land last
if I were to sort of it was if I was an
alien and arrived at Earth and say
choice of land maybe if you were
interested in uh create choosing a land
that represents a network state where
ideas that unites a people
uh based on ideas maybe pick a land that
doesn't lead to uh generational conflict
and War so I'll get to that destruction
and suffering and all that also that's
right so so now that I've said what are
you know the positive things about
Israel and I think there's a lot to
admire initial as I said I think there's
also a lot to matter in the Palestinians
and so on I'm not taking any position on
that there's other Inspirations for the
network State the second major
inspiration is India which managed to
achieve independence non-violently
right that's very important right so can
you can you fuse these things right
State started with a book that achieved
Independence non-violently okay and that
managed to build this polyglot you know
Multicultural democracy right that does
you know like you know India has its
flaws but it does manage to have you
know human rights of lots of people
respected and what have you right
and um has managed to you know there
were times like emergency in the 1970s
and they're gone the declared emergency
there were times when seeing touch and
go but overall with fits and starts this
flawed thing has kind of made its way
through and you know the third
inspiration is Singapore with Lee Kuan
Yew who built a city-state from nothing
you know I shouldn't say it from nothing
okay there was something there but let's
say I built one of the richest countries
in the world without like huge amounts
of Natural Resources in the middle of a
Zone where there was lots of Communist
Revolution going on
um and so he was the CEO founder
essentially of this amazing startup
country right and
um you know finally of course America
which has too many influences to name
things we talked about the nation of
immigrants obviously the Constitution
and so on and you think okay can we go
you think of uh you know these
Inspirations what's interesting about
these four countries by the way Israel
India Singapore and the US they have
something in common you know what that
is who's that they're all Forks of the
UK code base
we think obviously you know the UK was
sort of the ancestor of America but
Israel was a former British colony right
the India was a British colony and so is
Singapore right and for people who don't
know what fork and code base means it's
uh language from versioning systems
particularly git represented online on a
website called GitHub and a fork means
you copy the code and all the changes
you make to the code now live in their
own little world so America took the
ideas that defined the United Kingdom
and then
forked it by evolving those ideas in a
way that didn't affect the original the
original country that's right and what's
interesting about this is and of course
I'm saying that in a somewhat playful
way right but I think it's a useful
analogy and interesting analogy right so
you have the Americans who forked you
know the UK code base and you have you
know the Indians Israelis and the
singaporeans who also made their own
modifications and in some ways each
Society has pieces that you can take
from them and learn from them and try to
combine them right so you have a state
that is started by a book that
um non-violently assembles that
crowdfunds territory around the world
that
um is led by a CEO founder
um and that is also governed by
something that's like a constitution but
just like you went from you know I talk
about the V1 V2 and V3 a lot right like
V1 is gold and V2 is Fiat and V3 is
Bitcoin right or V1 is hunter gatherer
and v2's farmer Soldier V3 is digital
Nomad or Sovereign Collective okay which
is not just an individual but a group
um here V1 is UK common law they don't
have a constitution it's all precedent
going for many years right V2 is the US
Constitution and V3 is the Smart
contract the social smart contract which
is a you know Fusion obviously of
Rousseau's concept of the social
contract and the smart contract the
social smart contract is like written in
code okay so it's like even more
rigorous in the Constitution and in many
ways you can think of going from the
United Kingdom of uh England Wales you
know Scotland Northern Ireland the
United States of America the network
states of the internet okay where you go
from the rights of Englishmen with the
Magna Carta to Europeans
African-Americans all the immigrants to
the the you know the Americans or the um
you know North America then you've got
all the people of the world
and uh so you you basically are more
democratic and you're more capitalist
because you're talking about internet
capitalism not just Niche and state law
capitalism in a sense it's the V3 right
another way it's a V3 only about two
percent of the world
um is uh over 35 native born American
can qualify to be president of the
United States
but 100 of the world you could become
the president of a network state there
might be a you know Palestinian
Washington or a you know Brazilian
Hamilton right and now rather than say
okay maybe you're maybe you have a small
percentage chance of immigrating to the
US and a small percent chance of your
descendant you know becoming like you
know a president now we can just say you
can start online
and you know what maybe this person is
so exceptional they have Americans
coming to their you know Network state
right you don't think that kind of thing
is possible with like the rich get
richer in a digital space too the people
with more followers
uh have friends that have followers and
they like I don't think it's a rich get
richer I think what happens is
um so this is an important concept it is
it's multi-axis right that is to say for
example
um just the introduction of the Bitcoin
axis right uh and those you because it
didn't exist pre-2009 now it exists
um those people who are rich in BTC
terms are only partially correlated with
those who are rich in USD terms there's
all these folks essentially BTC is
Bitcoin and USD is US dollar yes
so that's a new axis and eth is yet
another axis right you ethereum eth is
ethereum right so you are essentially
getting
new social systems which are actually
net inequality decreasing because before
you only had USD Millionaires and now
you have a new track and then another
track and another track right you have
different hierarchies different ladders
right and so on net you have more
ladders to climb and so it's not the
rich getting richer in fact old money in
some ways is a last to cryptocurrency
um old money and old States I think
those people who are the most focused on
you might call it reform I would call it
control okay the most focused on control
the old world who have the least
incentive to switch
they will the rich will get poorer
because it will be the poor or those who
are politically powerless politically
poor who go and seek out these new
States yeah I I didn't mean in the
actual money but yes okay there's other
ladders I meant in in terms of influence
political and social influence in uh
these new network States you you I think
said that basically anybody can become
president of a network State just like
anybody can come see you of a startup
company of course whether people follow
you is another matter but anybody can go
and found one go ahead sorry oh from the
perspective that anyone can found one
anyone could found
I see we don't think it's implausible
that uh you know somebody from Brazil or
Nigeria I mean most quote billionaires
in the world are not American and in
fact actually here's another important
point it's far easier to become a tech
billionaire than become or a billionaire
period than become president of the
United States there's less than 50 U.S
presidents ever all time okay it is a
much more realistic ambition to become a
billionaire than become president
there's like thousands of billionaires
for what in fact 75 of them are outside
the US and many of those have been you
know some of them are like energy and
oil which is often based on political
connections but a very large chunk of
the rest are Tech okay and uh that's
something where you're mining but you're
mining online by hitting Keys as opposed
to the pickaxe you know and granite
right so the point is that we think it's
totally understandable today for there
to be a you know huge founder who comes
out of Vietnam or you know South America
like that like you can name Founders
from all over the world right
exceptional people can rise from all the
world to run giant companies why can
they not rise to run giant new countries
and the answer is we didn't developed a
mechanism yet right
um and just as another example I talked
about this in the book
the talibutarin is far more qualified
than Jerome Powell right or anybody at
the Federal Reserve he actually built a
car and managed a monetary policy in a
currency from scratch
okay as a 20-something right obviously
that's a more accomplished person than
somebody who just inherited an economy
this is a lot of people can push back at
that and say that the the people that
initially build a thing aren't
necessarily the best ones to manage a
thing once it scales and actually has
impact sometimes sometimes but Zuck has
done a good job of both I think vitalik
has done a good job of both right that's
not an inherent truth well so actually
you built the thing you'll be the best
person to run it I will agree with you
on that and actually I talk about this
in the book uh or I've got an essay on
this called founding versus inheriting
okay and the premise is actually that
the classic example you know the saying
shirt sleeves to shirt sleeves in three
generations it means the guy who starts
out poor and builds a fortune his son
maintains it and his dissipate grandson
dissipates it right why is short sleeves
a symbol of poverty back in the past it
was kind of like you know you're just
working with your you're not you're not
white collar you're back to working with
your hands you're just oh
yeah yeah we're working class or
something like that right so essentially
that the the grandson squanders it right
and you know in sense by the way
um just to talk about that for a second
if you have two children and four
grandchildren and eight
great-grandchildren and 16 and so on and
an older families you know they were
much bigger right six you know children
is not uncommon whatever Fortune you
have is now split six ways and then six
ways and six ways again so with the
exception of primogenature where the
oldest son inherits all the way down the
majority of your descent is just a few
Generations out have probably inherited
none of that fortune unless it has
compound to such an extent that it's
like up 6X over 20 years right so it's
actually hard to maintain a quote rule
in class in the sense that this person
who's like four generations down has you
know uh like 1 16 of the DNA you know
one over two to the fourth right
of their their cyan who built a fortune
so it's not even like the same is it the
same family even right there's a fortune
actually in the family so most people
don't think a few Generations out they
just kind of think oh Marx is right
there's always been a rich and a poor
it's actually much more Dynamic than
that because you literally like what is
even the family when it's diluted out
you know 1 16th right
um if you're 1 16 the Rockefeller are
you a rock filler really 15 16 something
else would you have the Rockefeller
Fortune probably not right now are
there's again primogenitor where the guy
who inherits the name all the way
through
um
that would be one way to pass it down
but even that person doesn't necessarily
have the qualities of the guy who you
know the cultural qualities of other
qualities guys like four generations
past they tend to squander it right so
this actually brings us to you know
coming back up to governance the system
the the guys who built the United States
you know like Washington and Hamilton
these are giants right these are
founders and the the folks today are
like not the the grandson but like the
40th generation heir of a factory that
somebody else built like think about a
factory and you have you know this
grandchild or great grandchild that
inherits a factory most the time it's
just cranking out widgets and the Greek
grandson is cashing checks they have
been selected as legitimate air because
it's the you know the founder passes
down to his son Pastor Jones's grandson
just great grandson so legitimacy is
there they've got title they can show I
own this Factory okay they can cash the
checks there's professional managers
there everything seems fine until one
day that factory has to go from making
you know widgets to making masks for
covet or something else it has to change
directions to do something it hasn't
done before none of that capability for
invention and reinvention is present
anymore these people have inherited
something that they could not build from
scratch because they could not build
from scratch they can't even maintain it
this is an important point the ability
to build from scratch is so important
because if some part breaks and you
don't know why it was there can you even
maintain it no you can't okay unless all
all the replacement parts in the
know-how to fit them together is there
you can't repair this so in 2009 Mother
Jones had a story that said that the U.S
military had forgotten how to make some
kinds of nuclear weapons because there
was a part
where all the guys who knew how to make
it had like aged out or left okay and
this was some like Arrow gel or
something like that it was it was
rumored okay
thing is
um you're seeing you know increasingly
for example you've got uh wildfires in
California you've got you know water
that's not potable in Jackson you've got
power outages in Texas
um you're seeing a lot of the
infrastructure of the US is just less
functional I think probably part of that
is due to civil engineering not being
that sexy a field people aging out and
just domain knowledge being lost and The
Heirs who win you know the role of mayor
or whatever of this town don't have the
ability to build it from scratch you're
just select for legitimacy not
competence okay so once you think about
this concept of founding versus
inheriting and I've got the whole essay
which talks about this
um of course the alternative to somebody
who's legitimate but not competent what
people will say is oh we need like uh
you know an authoritarian to be in
control of everything and then their
their hope is that that person is
competent but they don't have legitimacy
because if they're just installed it's
just like a authoritarian ruler 50 of
the population is really mad at them
they don't have title just grab the
title you know maybe they can exert
enough Force that's the problem with
kind of the authoritarian you know
dictator takeover right so the
alternative the third version is the
founder who combines both legitimacy and
confidence because they start from
scratch and they attract people to their
vision and they build it from scratch
and so you need this ability to
constantly do refoundings rebirths